an organizer of the other program that's
going on this semester this is on the
geometry of monomials
Nikhil Shrivastava is tell us about that
it's at the intersection of theoretical
computer science and mathematics
okay so thanks okay so I'm gonna tell
you about this program were running
called geometry of polynomials so this
is sort of a funny name it suggests that
this is a field that has something to do
with geometry or algebra but it really
is mostly having to do with analysis so
this is a term that was coined sometime
in the early 20th century and it refers
to a field which studies the zeros of
comp multivariate polynomials with
complex roots the the reason it had this
name is to distinguish it from algebraic
geometry there's already a huge field
which studies the rows of complex
polynomials but this is about analysis
so it's maybe the most concrete way to
tell you you know somehow what the
themes of this field are if you just
need to study the simplest example so
let's suppose I have a multi very since
we'll have a univariate polynomial P
with complex coefficient and degree n ok
so this is something we've we've all
seen and you know basic observation is
that there are three different ways of
thinking about this polynomial so the
mode you know may be the most concrete
one is just to list the coefficients you
have these n plus 1 numbers that are the
coefficients but then there's this this
other way which is instead of writing as
a sum you can write it as a product and
the factors in the product tell you what
the zeroes of the polynomial are so this
is an alternate representation in terms
of zeros and then finally you can also
just think of the polynomial as a
function from complex numbers to complex
numbers you can think of this object in
three different ways and you know once
you have this you can ask all sorts of
questions like what happens to one of
these things when I change at some of
the other ones right like if I apply
some transformation of the coefficients
what happens to the zeros and vice-versa
so you know maybe one of the first
theorems in this area which really is a
prototype for much of what follows is
the the Gauss Lucas theorem so this is
like from 1800 something like that and
I'm just gonna tell you what this
theorem says with a picture so let's
suppose I have a polynomial P of Z of
degree 4 and let's say these are zeros
in the complex plane so now I can ask
the question well what's gonna happen
when I differentiate this polynomial
right so that's some natural operation
on the polynomial when I differentiate a
polynomial of degree 4 I'm gonna get a
polynomial of degree
three so it's gonna have some three
other zeros and you could ask well
what's the relationship between the
zeros of the derivative and the zeros of
the original polynomial and it turns out
there's a very nice answer to this so
the gospel just theorem says that well
the zeros of the derivative are
contained in the convex hull of the
zeros of the polynomial that's the
simplest example of it maybe interesting
theorem in this area but this is the
type of thing that's studied in this
field you apply some transformation do
you know one side of this picture what
happens to the other side okay so this
is this is an old field our program is
about applying this perspective of
polynomials and these transformations on
polynomials and they're zeros to study
phenomena in computer science okay so so
you know the the rough unifying idea of
much of the research that's going on is
you want to study some object like a
graph or maybe like you have some convex
set or something we find some way to
encode it as a multivariate polynomial
and then now this polynomial has
coefficients it has zeros it has some
properties of the function and you use
this inner player to prove interesting
theorems about whatever it is you and
our program has this thing I mean at
least three different clusters of people
and directions to go with this so the
first cluster is you know studying
discrete phenomena of interest in
computer science I guess traditional
algorithms and complexity probability
and combinatorics I would say more about
this in a moment the second is in
statistical physics of statistical
physicists have been using generating
polynomials to describe physical systems
for a long time they're called partition
functions in physics and the third group
is Riyadh's break geometry and
optimization so it turns out you can
define all sorts of interesting convex
sets in RN using different classes of
polynomials so so so roughly you know
the reason we're having the program now
is it this perspective of studying these
zeros has led to major results in all
three of these areas and also to new
connections between them that were sort
of less clear previously so you know
given that that's the cancer program has
really got three different communities
of people who aren't so used to talking
to each other and one of the goals is to
have these connections it's to develop
these connections so so let me just give
you a flavor let me tell you three of
the results recently proven by members
of the program which may be more
interesting they're also representative
of some of the ideas so this is
something which they already heard a
little bit about so so so so this is a
result which shows how to sample
efficiently from any from the basis of
any matric
so what's the problem so you're given
may tried em where the ground set is a
set of n elements and there's a set of
basis you don't know the matron is just
think of the set of spanning trees of a
graph okay so if I give you a graph on n
vertices it has exponentially many
spanning trees are probably not given
this thing as a list you're given this
as as an Oracle so what that means is
given any set you can check whether it's
in this beer and and the goal is to
generate a uniformly random sample
from the set of basis of this matrix
this captured a lot of problems that are
actually used in applications for
example determinantal point processes
though they're a special case with this
and the theorem due to is that the the
natural Markov chain Monte Carlo our
algorithm I won't say what it is for for
this for sampling a random element a
random basis mixes rapidly so you can do
this very efficiently and again the way
this is proven is by there's no
polynomial in this question but the way
this is proven is you write down a
multivariate generating function of this
polynomial sum over all the bases you
write down some generating function a
multivariate generating function and
then it turns out that various convexity
properties of the generating function
give you this result okay so in this
problem your goal is to sample a random
coefficient of this polynomial by a
Markov chain but somehow the reason you
were able to do it was by studying its
properties of the function the second
the second example is which is different
area is algorithms for approximating
partition functions okay so this is
something that comes from statistical
physics one one example of a partition
function is let's say you're given some
graph G
and the partition function is a
generating function which counts some
interesting structure in the graph so
I'm just gonna write one on the board
let's say you you you write down the
partition function that counts the
independent sets of the graph so this is
a polynomial of degree n where n is the
number of vertices it's just X to the I
where I is X to the I times let's say mi
where mi is the number of independent
sets of size hi okay given a graph you
can write this generating function for
intercepts if you could evaluate this at
some interesting points it's a way of
counting weighted way of counting the
independent set and again there's
sequence of results by people several
former and the program's not a
comprehensive list saying so the theorem
is you can efficiently approximate
this function for values of x that are
far from the zeros of this polynomial
again there's this interplay like our
goal is to find the to evaluate this
polynomial and the places where you can
do it exactly have to do it where the
zeros of this lie and again some of
these algorithms are real algorithms
they're not like some other algorithms
that you can't code they're they
actually run faster on a computer wait
two minutes including questions okay
well okay the last one I won't describe
in detail but basically many people may
be familiar with semi-definite
programming that's optimization over a
certain class of convex cones you can
view the positive definite cone as a
zero free region of the determinant
polynomial a certain zero free region of
it determinant polynomial and now you
can plug in a much more general class of
polynomials and get a generalization of
seven different programming like
robotics programming and it's sort of
it's a mystery exactly how much more
powerful this is that semi definite
program so this is geometric question
where you get a geometric object from
looking at the zero free region of a
polar okay anyway if you're interested
in this here a few buzz words if you
want to search on the internet but I
hope you got it
one minute for question so has the three
groups you mentioned the three groups
have been have been mixing perhaps not
as rapidly as that algorithm but they've
been they've been slowly mixing yeah
[Applause]